we are getting new and devastating
details coming out of the astroworld
festival tragedy that killed eight
people lauren you were in houston on the
ground you talked to some of the folks
who were lucky enough to escape kev one
woman who i spoke to said it was and i
quote worse than hell and as more stars
speak out houston native megan the
stallion is sharing her heartbreak
[Music]
i feel terrible whatever we could do i
want to help and we're just sending
prayers and we're sending condolences
and we're sending positive energy to
everybody in that family houston native
megan the stallion is sending love to
victims as 17 lawsuits so far have been
filed they allege scott and live nation
were negligent and each seeks over one
million dollars in damages we need
somebody to help hope somebody passed
out right here
claims include the concert was a death
trap a complete melee and predictable
and preventable
drake who made a surprise appearance
with scott is named as a co-defendant in
one suit for inciting violence if i
don't want thee
from the front to the back
we better make the
earthquake
one of those filing a lawsuit the father
of ezra blount the nine-year-old houston
boy who is in a coma my son once he had
passed out from the pressure being
applied to him during the concert
he passed out and ezra fell into the
crowd when my son awakened
ezra wasn't there so he was making a
frantic search to find ezra we just want
there to be accountability and
transparency of who did what
before travis scott put his foot on the
stage they should have gotten that crowd
under control
i sat down today with renowned crowd
safety expert paul wertheimer he says
there are three things you can do if
caught in a crowd crush
one is not to yell and scream and use up
your limited oxygen the other thing is
not to fight the crowd surge you can't
fight a thousand pounds of pressure or
more the third thing is
to pray
that someone will reach you in time
we know about other big music festivals
austin city limits coachella do you see
them changing their protocols after
astroworld
not if they don't have to change and not
if they don't want to change it just
drones on and there will be more
disasters
[Music]
you